why are you setting yourself up to fail
when there's so many people in this
world already trying to do that for you
there's one of you in this world you're
in this world for a very short period of
time whether you think it's long or not
it's short do something magical in it
hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning in this week's episode of
deep dive i chat to chrissy chella
chrissy first started posting fitness
videos on instagram and youtube in 2017
while studying for a law degree fast
forward four years and chrissy has built
a health and fitness empire with the
mission to empower women across the
world there's a huge problem in the
world
where women lack confidence like i
perceive that as a problem chrissy is
co-founder of the tone and sculpt app
fitness clothing brand honor active and
an internationally respected personal
trainer in the episode we have a very
honest conversation about the
foundations of leading multi-million
dollar brands how to find your why and
her book do this for you do this for you
to me means prioritizing yourself
and
taking care of yourself and not putting
yourself bottom on the list
and i think that
people tend to really prioritize other
people their needs how other people
perceive them
that you tend to kind of neglect what
how you perceive yourself and where you
prioritize yourself
um
and it's not even to do with other
people it's also to do with things like
students always prioritize their
studying before themselves and their
health right moms prioritize their
children over
themselves
people prioritize their job more than
themselves and it's like you come bottom
to the list
and then by the time you want to do
something for yourself you're too
exhausted yeah and there's a real sense
of
uh martyrdom almost in a way where i
think
parents feel good that they're
prioritizing their kids and students
feel like it's it's almost a badge of
honor to have pulled an all-nighter and
to be prioritizing your studies for
whatever reason um i guess i i guess
there is a balance there right like or
how how how do you see
for for example for you i imagine your
your business is fairly top of mind and
you're thinking about it a lot yeah but
also there's the taking care of yourself
aspect and do you ever find that the two
are sometimes conflicting for that top
spot
i think i've found a balance now
i've found a balance where
like i've said to my entire team you
know i've said to
to my personal assistant like no
meetings before 10 o'clock
and i've made that very clear to
everyone and i've said i wake up at 5 30
in the morning i'm waking up at 5 30 in
the morning to prioritize my health and
myself
so i'm in the gym at six o'clock in the
morning
i'm there training an hour
sometimes dependent hour and a half if i
really have the time but maximum one
hour in and out
you know i'm eating my breakfast i'm
going through my emails i'm reading some
sort of book in the morning so when i
get to the office
i'm ready to give you my 110
attention
because had i not done all those things
i'm then going to have this constant
battle
of oh my god i haven't trained today i
haven't prioritized myself i haven't
done anything for myself
and then by the time i do go home i'm so
exhausted i'm so overwhelmed i just want
to lay on the on the sofa and watch
netflix yeah and
that's not really doing something for me
to bettering me yeah so i guess you've
got those four and a half hours in the
morning to do the use stuff and then you
can focus fully on the business yeah
like even
my commute is an hour sometimes an hour
and a half
so in my commute you know i tend to take
my dog buttons with me so she's always
on the train with me and you know it's
quite nice doing that together but i'm
always either reading something
listening to some sort of podcast i'm
i'm getting myself mentally prepped for
my team
my companies as much as people think my
companies are about me
they're not my companies are about the
people that drive the mission and the
vision um it's about the employees every
single day coming
to the office working from home
dedicating their time to make this
vision come true
so if i'm coming into the office
expecting everybody else to be on their
a game i have to be on my a-game
and i can't come in and be angry or
emotional or over you know just just not
be myself and there has been too many
moments i've done that
and it's caused a really big division in
the company it really has because i've
come in thinking i can be the way i want
to be
well no i'm
a leader i have to be
collective i have to be calm i have to
you know prioritize my team over my own
emotions and i've learned that the hard
way oh interesting any
was there one occasion in particular
that that helped you helped you learn
that lesson i don't think enough leaders
actually speak about this i think
there's so many entrepreneurs
and ceos leaders whatever
and they come across like they have
their [ __ ] together right like they've
just like
they're the calmest people in the world
like they've got it all figured out and
the truth is every leader is different
there is no handbook to be given to how
you should be as a leader one thing you
should always have is empathy
for the team that you're working with
and one thing you should always have is
patience and i was never patient
okay i when i started tone and sculpt or
honor active i was never ever patient
um i was actually way too emotionally
connected to both brands that i used to
take everything personally okay
and now as the years have gone on
especially with toner sculpt because
it's more older than honor active
i have to take a step back and i have to
go this has nothing to do with me the
mission and the vision is so much
greater and bigger
than any emotion i have you talk a lot
about vision and mission um yeah when
did you figure out what your vision
mission and stuff was
and how did you figure that out because
there's a big question like it's a
question of what you want to do with
your life
yeah i mean look
it's not been
until very recent
that i'm
110 focused on that vision and mission
now
at first i was a bit like
what is it what i know i'm i want to do
something here but
i can't put my finger on it i couldn't
put my finger on it all i knew and was
certain on for years was i wanted to
help women
like i was certain on that thing how did
how did you get certain on that because
that's also quite a
it's
it's not so specific but it's like a it
it's a very specific kind of kind of
dream yeah yeah the reason being is when
i started my
instagram and my youtube i was doing
this for myself right okay and then i
was
connecting with all these women globally
saying i don't have time to go to the
gym i don't know what i'm doing i feel
so rejected so neglected i feel like i'm
just letting myself down and i realized
there was such a need
for
women to come together
and there was such a need for fitness to
be in women's lives it was like it was
it's a need like there's a there's a
huge problem in the world
where women lack confidence like i
perceive that as a problem
and i perceive
tonoscope as a solution okay to that
problem
so to me
i don't like the fact that there's so
many women out there who are not body
body confident who are not mentally
confident i don't like the fact that
women don't know what to do in their
fitness journey and feel really left
left out or alone
that's a huge problem to me because
your health
is the key to any form of success i
cannot stress that enough like if you
are not mentally and physically okay
it will
trans it will transpire into every
aspect of your life your relationship
your work your passion your vision
everything it will cloud you
that's why i say do this for you and
prioritize yourself first and then bring
your best foot forward for everything
else
so that's why i knew i wanted to help
women but i didn't know how i was going
to do it okay so when i launched the
toner sculpt up with my business partner
jack
i
sat down and i just said this is it
we are going to make
a fitness hub
that
is community orientated first
then fitness led secondary oh
interesting okay so
that's why community
is our vessel it's our heartbeat it's
our core okay we every decision we make
we ask what would the community need and
want first
um
our core values none of our core values
hold a
profit led value
it's our core values for tone and scope
are actually the following so long as
there's women in the world our business
to make women feel confident and better
their lives is not done
the second one is actually more team-led
so it's we have to treat each and every
single single team member with integrity
and honesty and countability everyone's
accountability for is with each other
and with themselves
third one is community-led so
our communities are driving force to
everything that we do so if they do not
like something then we won't do it it's
as simple as that
fourth one is customer support
and fifth is innovation okay so profit
is not even in our list profit is like
the last thing we actually think about
and that's genuinely we don't really
we don't even shove numbers down our
employees throats we say okay there's
women in this world your job here isn't
done
so i'm trying to build an organization
not just a social hub yeah
interesting uh i want to ask you more
about the values thing in a moment
because we're literally going through
that sort of value stuff with our team
now because we've got
like this week we hired seven people so
we're now on 19. wow congratulations
it's huge yeah but every people like you
know you make youtube videos watching 19
people and i'm like well you'd be
surprised when you draw the org chart
and you see all the holes that you're
like um but before we go there uh i want
to ask about the early days so you were
posting workout
workout videos on instagram
what was the growth like how did things
start growing in the very early days
before you knew that this could become
like a career for you yeah i mean
it's huge growth huge growth and like i
said no one was really doing what i was
doing and a handful of creators were
doing back in the day
and
you know if you go on youtube about 10
years ago it was heavily
bodybuilder orientated so you had people
trying to be bikini bodies
and and people were genuinely selling
bikini body guides and they were selling
bikini programs and it was heavily based
on being on stage as well and being a
professional bodybuilder
and i just didn't fit in
because i was like oh my god i just want
to go to the gym to escape my reality
like literally i'm so sick of my life i
just want to go somewhere and do
something for myself yeah and
that's when i started posting and all my
captions were like hi like i went to the
gym today and i did a few squats and i
felt so much better how about you do it
too and
it was very like
it i it was very premature and it was
very like it was
it was very like vulnerable and it was
very authentic it was it was genuine
and i remember when i was growing i was
a waitress at the time
and a law student
and i grew to about 120 000 followers
and women's best approach me women's
best is the biggest female supplement
brand in the world
um
they're huge absolutely massive
now like i think their evaluation will
be close to a billion
so that they're massive
um
and they approached me and i got an
email saying hi we love your instagram
like we'd love to work with you on a
collaborative basis and i said
i've never really tried your supplements
um i'll give them a go and i'll see
what's what because i'd never done a
collaboration before
so i didn't know how it worked i've
never had a manager until the day i
don't have a manager um
so they sent me supplements after three
four months of testing them
seeing what i like what didn't like
giving them honest feedback my problem
is i'm a bit too honest for my own good
i just zip my mouth sometimes but hey ho
and i was like yeah i really like it
like this is you're onto something good
here i like it
and i was finding myself having the
supplements more often than i would
because i enjoyed it
and it was there to supplement the diet
i already had right i didn't rely on it
and then women's best gave me enough
funds monthly to quit my job i still
remained a law student i when i start
something i need to follow it through i
just i'm just like that
and i started posting more often like
they supported me you know
and at that time i'd reached about 600
000 followers and jim shark came
knocking on my door
and
i actually rejected the first
contract i didn't want to work with them
um
i didn't really understand it at the
start
and then when i got to know the brand a
bit more and then i got to know
you know
that they had a vision to you know they
had a mission to
um
[Music]
i started i started working with them
it was short-lived but i'm so thankful
for the opportunity i'm so thankful that
they
gave me the opportunity to travel the
world with them and meet so many
community members
and i'm so thankful for the learning so
thankful for the opportunities that they
gave me with photo shoots with meeting
other peers with meeting such incredible
minds and
you know even though it was short-lived
every opportunity is an absolute
blessing and it makes me so happy to see
brands genuinely succeed at the rate
that they have
when i started when they were quite
small
so
it just it's inspiring because it's like
if they can do it we can do it
that's the way i perceive it yeah and
yeah the growth was substantial i i hit
a million followers within i think two
years
um then straight into two million
followers a year after
now i'm to 2.5
the growth is definitely different
because the market is utterly saturated
now
um
and tick tock is obviously just come in
god knows where
um
but that's why i can't stress enough
that i'm not chasing the grove
i am chasing the fact that there's only
one chrissy chella
do you know what i'm trying to say like
i'm gonna share with you my own thoughts
and my own vision if you like it great
if you don't that's no problem but i'm
not gonna follow trends anymore it's too
draining for me in the early days let's
say kind of going from like like you
know zero zero to a hundred thousand was
it a case that you were sort of just
just sort of posting stuff because you
felt like it or did you feel this like
yeah no no i felt no pressure okay no
pressure i felt like it i really enjoyed
it i was posting daily i was posting
every day at five o'clock
everyone knew what they were getting
it was a workout video or it was a
picture it was some sort of food as well
everyone knew what they were getting
like they knew what they were getting i
was posting regularly i still post
regularly now i've never stopped not
posting regularly
but it was just very authentic okay and
it wasn't chasing some kind of numbers i
wasn't thinking
i could get to a million if i did more
videos or not not then right it wasn't
until i probably hit about 300 000
followers where i was like um
like there's substantial growth here i
think at one point i grew i was growing
like 10 000 a day
yeah it was ridic it was ridic it was
honestly ridiculous growth and
and
yeah i mean i was i was chasing the
growth then okay so then some of the
decisions were very growth led instead
of authenticity and being true to myself
led okay such as such as like oh my god
there was a state a phase where
peers would ask each other to repost
each other's
pictures on their stories and game of
followers or like for like
and you would ask like big accounts to
post you
it was very heavily
numbers driven and i lost sight
completely because i was just like the
bigger i am the more brands will want to
work with me the more guess what i don't
work with any other brand but my own and
women's best and i've been working with
us for five years i don't do any paid
collaborations i've even told my pr team
don't give me paid collaborations i
don't want to do it i'm not interested
in it
even if they give me a million i'm not
interested in it unless it's a brand
that i've like lived by for like
five six seven ten years of my life in
those early days as you you know you go
from being kind of waitress plus law
student into suddenly having this
enormous following on the internet
and
and it's within the field of like being
a woman and doing the fitness stuff
that's got to be a lot of
pressure there'll be a lot of baggage
pressure like what was what was that
experience like because you're like a
normal normal university student who
seemed to have stumbled into this like
incredible growth i think it's a lot of
pressure because i was young i still am
young but you know when it all started i
was
i was
early 20s like an early 20 year old
is like doing things they'll regret when
they're 30 or you know what i mean i'll
talk about when they're 50 and laugh
about it with their friends and at uni i
was a bit of a loner i was a bit of a
loner i had probably like one or two
friends
um
i remember this girl called juliana she
was so lovely and like always so
welcoming
but i just kept myself to myself i was
working full-time i was trying to get my
law degree and if i wasn't working
full-time i was trying to grow
my own personal brand and you know
trying to grow my community so i was so
focused because it didn't feel like work
it felt like a passion
university to me was actually almost
like my escape
from
the career i was trying to build and the
person
yeah there was a lot of pressure but
i'm so thankful that everything has
happened the way it has happened
i'm so thankful for the mistakes i made
with tone and sculpt in the early years
i'm so thankful for
you know being in a relationship with
jack who is my business partner still to
this day and
i was with him for five years we were
engaged it didn't work but we still
sustained tone and sculpt together and
we have so much respect for each other
like
he
he is
one of a kind you know and yes it didn't
work romantically but we share the same
vision and mission so our emotions come
secondary for one another because we
have a bigger role in this universe hmm
were you ever worried about what your
uni friends would say about the fact
that you're posting world cup videos and
you're not posting yourself give a [ __ ]
sorry how did you
i didn't give a [ __ ] so that's why i was
like yeah
i'm gonna i'm not gonna i'm not even
gonna lie like i don't care i don't care
what i didn't care what my
team thought of me when i was a waitress
and posting instagram videos i didn't
care what my
professors thought of me what my
university friends told me i didn't care
like i loved it so much
that i didn't care like my dad is balkan
right my dad comes from albania he's a
strict dad
when you're around my dad growing up you
can be wearing mini skirts and you
couldn't be like
doing things like that right so
for my dad to go on instagram to see his
daughter in shorts like mike pro shorts
squatting and
it was a bit much for him like it took
like he hated it he sat me down he goes
you need to stop like this is this is
not good for our for our family
and i was like
no i don't care
what anyone has to say like i'm so sick
and tired of people trying to dictate
who i'm gonna be yeah and for so long i
let
my previous boyfriend do that like the
one that cheated on me for so many years
dictate how i felt who i was going to be
how i should be treated
since then i thought no way it happened
once i'm never letting that happen again
not my friends not my family not my
co-workers no but not by about like
partners no not by nothing
that's a pretty remarkable level of
confidence to be able to do all of that
and just like i've reached that level
where i'm like if you don't like me
it's no problem if you do phenomenal
let's get dinner together the bottom
line is we should never ever ever judge
someone for trying to put good in the
world like i wasn't doing anything wrong
i was i'm genuinely trying to put good
in this world i'm trying so hard daily
to build two brands that prevail women's
confidence that when you put on our
active on you're like
[ __ ] i look good i feel good i look good
i'm trying to build a platform with tone
and sculpt where a woman's confidence
just skyrockets i'm trying to put good
in this world i'm not i'm not doing
anything wrong so if someone wants to
judge that that's on them not me
so
you said earlier on that um
one of the issues that you want to kind
of solve is
women's under confidence yes
i i imagine a lot of people in your
community are in that sort of beginner
stage where they can't imagine having
that level of confidence where you can
just i don't know post a workout video
and not care what other people think
what do you think are sort of the and
you you've got a chapter in the book
where you talk about this but what would
you say are those are the steps for
someone to get to that level of
confidence where they're comfortable
putting themselves out there in that
capacity
and i guess i'm asking because because a
lot of people who who watch this channel
and and listen to the podcast
they're interested in becoming creators
in some capacity but the number one
question when we ask people what's your
biggest challenge with being a creator
it's i'm scared of what my friends and
family will think i'm scared of what my
mom's going to say scared of what my
cousins will think scared of what people
in school are going to say at uni or my
job i'm scared i'm not going to get a
job 10 years down the line when people
discover my my youtube channel all of
these fears around what other people
will think
how yeah
any any thoughts
i think um
if you automatically doubt what you want
to do or you want to put fear as your
main driven emotion to what you're doing
you're setting yourself up to fail
like you've already kind of just it's
almost like when people start their
fitness journeys right they go
oh yeah i'll try it but i know it's not
going to work
yeah like you've kind of and then when
it doesn't work because for whatever
reason they go i see i knew i knew it
wouldn't work so yeah this is how
there's no point me doing ever again
you're already setting yourself up to
fail like why are you doing that to
yourself
why are you setting yourself up to fail
when there's so many people in this
world already trying to do that for you
right there's already other people in
the world judging you why are you going
to add more unnecessary pressure to
yourself right
there's one of you in this world you're
in this world for a very short period of
time whether you think it's long or not
it's short
right do something magical in it do
something so extraordinary that it makes
other people want to do it too that
makes other people want to go
damn
i want to give that a go because she did
it or he did it
and yes you're gonna have judgment so be
prepared for it like people will say
what are you doing like my own dad sat
me down and was like what are you doing
like it's embarrassing i'll never forget
that conversation now he's living his
best life because i bought him a home
and new teeth
like
like
you just have to go for it you have to
go for that leap you have to get that
that that
passion in you and
drive yourself forward because it's such
a waste if you don't yeah and also like
what would you tell your kids
like if my daughter came to me and was
like mom
i'm gonna start posting on instagram i
don't know how it's gonna go but i'm
just gonna give it a go i'd be like go
for it
do you want me to go record you yeah
go for it and people are forgetting now
like there's tick tock stars making
millions a year
and making careers for life and there's
youtube stars like literally
going to
you know the met gala whatever it's
called and sitting down with some of the
most influential people in the world
these are now jobs like they're real
jobs people
unfortunately don't want to become
lawyers anymore they want to become
a trainer online helping with millions
of women
so as speaking of the law thing so you
so you finished your law degree yeah um
but you decided to not do the lawyer
thing because you had all this other
stuff going for you um
was that a difficult choice that you
made at the time no i pursued this thing
okay
i was so i don't know where this
confidence comes from
one day someone's gonna come knock it
the hell down but
i was so confident
i was so like
this isn't what i want to do like why am
i even entertaining it like my job on
this planet my duty on this planet is to
help women okay
that's that's that's my that's my
driving force to help women so i'm not
gonna entertain anything else like i
haven't entertained anything else i'm so
tunnel vision so okay so it's it's it's
the early days the instagram account is
great is growing you've got the deal
from women's best yeah and how how did
you decide the next step was to
do tone and sculpt i gained my personal
training qualification because i i
thought to myself if i'm putting this
out on social and i'm
essentially telling people how i live my
life
i want to be able to advise people
further and be well more educated and
rounded
so i got my level two and my level three
qualification so i was all qualified in
that field and the thing is of me i'm
quite addicted to learning
so even outside of school i was actually
a pain in the arson school no teacher
liked me but one so no they actually
never thought i'd get to uni so okay
yeah here i am but whatever i i did it
to myself but anyway i was always
addicted to learning but in my own way
i never liked being told what to do so i
hated that so i always liked learning
though i really enjoyed it
so i started learning about
fitness and how the body works and
nutrition and just was so intrigued by
it
that i was like you know what
i'm going to build an app okay
i'm going to build an app
did you have like a coding background or
anything like that no no no no no how
did that so at the time random thing to
just decide to do right yeah yeah no we
had pdfs we had um so started pdf then
digital digital platform we're going to
take a very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode and that is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last two plus years they're a
fantastic platform for learning maths
science and computer science with
engaging and interactive online courses
and the great thing about brilliant is
that they really teach stuff from a very
first principles based approach it's
almost like the way that we were taught
in places like oxford and cambridge
where you learn a concept and then you
apply the concept to an interesting
problem rather than just being spoon-fed
stuff like we initially learned in
school my favorite courses on brilliant
are the computer science ones as some of
you guys might know i was torn between
applying to medicine and computer
science i went for medicine in the end
but i always had an affinity to computer
science and taking the courses on
brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode i
built my app um with a third party oh
how did that go
yes with a third party um and they tried
to [ __ ] me over big time oh
so they tried to take the app away and
basically say that they own everything
and that i only own the content okay
who wants to own a content on an app
yeah you want to own the data code so if
you're out there building an app
data and code and interface is the most
important thing that you can have not
just the content you put in like the
pretty pictures and the workouts you
know
so after like 50 grand in legal fees
and one relationship broken mind and my
fiances the app was officially ours so
mine and jax
because it's completely owned by us now
yeah
what was that like when you when you
first found out that they were there was
no official contract and when the
contract was given to me with my
background as a law student i read
through it and knew this was wrong okay
and i just would not agree to the terms
this was after they made the app already
oh interesting
the app was already made already
launched okay and then they give you a
contract saying oh by the way we
we own all the intellectuals
yeah and i said no okay and what
happened next
well the app wouldn't have survived if i
didn't promote it right yeah so the app
is mine
just because you build the coding no
problem i'll pay you for that
but you can't tell me you're gonna own
my app for the rest of my life
that means like all the new trainers
we've brought in hundreds and thousands
of women subscribed to the app you're
telling me you own all that
that wouldn't also make the community
feel comfortable
that would make the community feel
really uncomfortable knowing that this
third party had all this information
like no
now it's 100 owned by tony scott we are
self-funded we've we're not with any
other parties we own everything we
protect everything we protect our
community it's in in our hands so if we
mess up it's our fault okay yeah it's
nobody else's fault i can't run to
someone and blame them it's my blame so
so is is that why you decided that okay
you know what we need to fight this
we're going to embark on this like messy
legal battle type situation
i was happy to go down 10
50 100
i was ready to sell my house like i
genuinely was ready to sell my house
hand on my heart i know my mother's life
i was i looked at jack at the time and i
said i don't care i'm not losing this
app i will sell this house i will sell
our car we will go live back with your
mom and dad but no one has taken this
thing away from us because this is
purposeful like we have something
as we have something so
legitimately
powerful for this world
i'm not giving that up like are you
crazy never okay so
yeah how did you win the win the battle
in the end balanced probability it was
more towards my favor
my my um
towards
favoriting me than the other party okay
so what they like
did it go to like a jury and all that
no we settled
eventually because i just said look i'm
ready to sell my house
so to get the best lawyer there ever it
is yeah we did really genuinely have the
most amazing noise my lawyer but
um yeah and i think it's important for
people to hear this stuff because a lot
of people think it was just like happy
days
more happy than bad of course but
you know like a lot happens behind the
scenes that that's why i'm so passionate
about
tone and sculpt and if anything my
passion's grown more um and it's just
i'm so consistent in the same goal like
i'm consistent in believing the same
thing it hasn't changed since day one
okay awesome so you've got the app now
and then you launched the uh uh
interactive sportswear brand was it
about a year ago yes a year mark's
except in september 21st it was a year
so what was the story behind that how
did you decide that the next step after
after the app the community was your own
your own clothing line
so the next stage after that for me was
okay so
i'm a woman in fitness
i train every day i have a community of
thousands of women training with me
let me make them also look extraordinary
like i'm helping you feel extraordinary
let me make you look extraordinary
and
i thought it was really
powerful to have a woman
you know
create clothing that women want to wear
okay and i thought there was something
really powerful behind that and i
thought that there was something really
clever behind that
and
every decision we make at honor active
is really um
yet again community-led but it's also
our core value is
to make products
that make people feel extraordinary in
performance and day-to-day activity
so
how do we do that how do we make people
feel extraordinary
is it the colors we choose so internally
i've built a formula called the color
formula
so we ensure that every color palette we
use
complements every skin tone in the world
um and like there's a huge project going
on behind the scenes where we're even
gonna bring in a skin specialist to tell
us what colors we should never go for
so regardless of me dying tomorrow i've
said in stone that these colors should
never be used but you can go towards
these colors so that means everybody can
can feel extraordinary in the colors we
use how about the fits
okay so it's our duty to ensure that we
have a fit for everyone how do we do
that well i'm really like proud to
announce that in december we're going to
launch our first double xl
range
so it helps even more people feel
extraordinary so loads of the decisions
we make are hugely calculative
and hugely based on our core value how
do you figure out what these core values
were
um you just have to ask yourself the
questions or why are you doing this like
it's very easy when you ask yourself why
are you doing this like you set yourself
in the room and you go
why did you feel like toner scope was
needed in this world
why did you feel like
there wasn't enough already out there
yeah and then you start listing all
these things and you're like
yeah those are our values okay
like why did i feel the need to create
on active
with my business partners like why did i
filter the need to do this
you start really
seeing it all come to life
there's insane brands out there brands
that
genuinely inspire me daily i just think
the bottom line is i'm so community
orientated and i want to listen to
women's and potentially one day men's
needs
to just give them what they need and
what they want in the book i think so
it's one of the early chapters you talk
about finding your why and you reference
simon sonic's book start with why um i
wonder
well when it comes to
sort of new entrepreneurs or people
starting out either entrepreneurship or
being a creator
to what extent do you think it's
important to start with
to start with that mission or purpose
because it's very important it's so
important it's so
important if you are
starting a brand if you want to start a
brand like if you don't know your why
just don't do it like i can't stress
that enough if you are starting a brand
to make money
oh like i don't know
okay no you should never start a brand
to make money
if your cor if your if your core
ideology is profit
if your core
value is we aim to make
100 million in the first five years if
that's your number one core value i'm
not saying it shouldn't be a core value
i'm saying if that's your number one
core value you're going to plummet
because every decision you make will be
profit led not mission led there's a
complete difference
so you need your why you need to know
why you want to start why you want to
start what is the reason
and it's a very big question to ask
yourself because you'll start
understanding
that it's deeper than what you first
perceived when women come to me and go i
really want to lose 10 pounds i go why
yeah why do why tell me why because i
really want to know why
oh because i know i look better okay but
why does that matter i know i'll feel
better okay but why
but why but why truth is
that bride that wants to lose 10 pounds
for her wedding day it's not that she
wants to lose 10 pounds is that she
wants to feel confident in her wedding
day so actually it's not about the
pounds she loses it's the effort she's
putting in daily
to feel confident on her wedding day
there's a complete difference so that
why is going to keep her driven longer
than constantly stepping on the scales
and seeing those numbers not shift yeah
i think it's similar on the let's say if
someone wants to start a youtube channel
if you if you do it for the sake of
wanting to make money from it
it's really hard to keep that motivation
going to sustain that if you do it for
the sake of chasing views it's really
hard to keep going but if you do it for
you get really sad
you're gonna get really upset
you're gonna think you're not good
enough you're gonna cross compare
you're going to just never be satisfied
i've been there like i can genuinely
speak from experience and you're going
to completely and truly [ __ ] your mind
up so one thing one thing i was
intrigued about was sort of your
one of your sort of life philosophies
that sounds like a grandiose way of
putting it but well one of your life
philosophies is that you don't see you
seem not you seem to not care about
goals
and that really resonates with me
because i also think goals are a bit
overrated and it's more about the
journey rather than about the
destination
um and that's something i've been i've
been like speeling on my youtube channel
for the last like four years and i read
that uh
in the book you said something along
that effect as well that like you know
it's it's less about the destination
it's not about like the motivation it's
not about the goal yeah you're gonna
elaborate on that rated yeah motivation
is so overrated like what oh she's just
drop like jarring and just just like
shut up like i hate her she's she comes
one day she leaves another day she's
there in a moment and then i'm like
where is she gone and then it's just
like
i can't be bothered with it and i can't
express enough
how you need to stop relying on
motivation and start relying more on
building consistency and discipline in
your day-to-day life
motivation is not something that you can
sustain for the rest of your life
because there's going to be moments
where you don't want to get out of bed
there's going to be moments where you
want to eat your favorite pizza and
watch netflix and skip the gym totally
fine there's going to be moments where
you actually don't want to come to work
even though it's your biggest passion
because you're tired you're drained
you're exhausted mentally and physically
but consistency is what makes you go
i'm going to go to the gym but i'm going
to come back home also and eat my pizza
and watch netflix with my partner
i'm going to go to work but only for two
hours
you know
it's it's that's what consistency is to
me
okay because you're sort of like showing
up showing up yeah because motivation to
me is either or
okay yeah i'd be the motivator to go for
that five k right now oh i don't go
like yeah yes okay consistency to me is
if i don't want to do it one day i'll go
for a little bit okay i'll give it a go
yep
if i
don't want to show up fine i'll take my
meetings from home
it's more flexible
it's more understanding
and i see these components as actual
humans that sounds really weird but
i see motivation as like this sassy diva
she sometimes wants to to go on stage
and give her best show but sometimes she
just wants to tell a teen to go away and
she's not going on stage then i see
consistency as like this really like
humble
genuine
person that wants to help you
and i think you should people need to
start perceiving certain elements as
personas because it will make you kind
of
distinguish which one you want to aim
for more yeah which one you want to
build a relationship with more
interesting okay so it's
it's you wake up in the morning your
alarm goes off at half past five and
you're thinking oh i'm feeling a bit
tired today
what do you what do you tell yourself
too this was the other day for me
actually i
my alarm went off at half five
ironically and then i was like oh
it's cold it's dark i'm in england
like it's too cold now yeah it's like
nearly november and i was i'm so tired i
don't want to go to the gym
and then i said to myself
right listen chrissy
go to the gym today
if you'd feel like this tomorrow give it
a miss
that's what i said to myself like and i
did today i didn't go to the gym i
didn't go to the gym i was still so
tired i gave myself an extra two hours
sleep instead
and that's what i needed yeah but if i'm
doing that every day
that's not good um one thing i wanted to
ask you about is
you talk about how we should
move towards um and steve stephen
bartlett talks about this as well kind
of
health being your foundation do it for
you that kind of stuff
but realistically i mean certainly for
me
the reason i go to the gym like i would
love for it to be for my own health and
for myself
but a big part of it is because i want
to look i want to look better i want i
don't know i
i want girls to be more attracted to me
that kind of stuff
um
to what extent
do you know that what if that's your
driving force then fine
like that's not a bad thing i just wanna
i just wanna i just wanna
say something because i think a lot of
people think that it's a bad thing to
have a physical goal when it's not like
it takes roughly three months to
incorporate a consistent habit into your
life right
if your goal for the next three months
is to look a certain way because you
want a bigger chest
six-pack abs whatever
great but guess what and behind the
scenes whether you like to think or not
you're building that consistency yeah so
when you get those abs you're still
gonna go you're still gonna it's gonna
be part of your life now right yeah so
if it is a physical
goal that's driving you no problem but
behind the scenes you're still building
that consistency
the only thing i would say is if
you're not getting that result that you
want to see or when you're stepping on
the scales and you're not seeing the
number shift
and then you're doing a 360 and
completely given up that's that's a
problem because then it's not you're not
you're not taking the time to build that
consistency and i can't stress enough
that if something is not sustainable in
your life you shouldn't be doing it
so if you're pushing yourself to do two
hours in the gym every single day
and that's not sustainable for your life
yeah stop doing it
if you can only train at home with a set
of dumbbells for 30 minutes do that
instead yeah because it's not really
about the short intense bursts that last
like a week because that's actually not
gonna have any impact at all exactly um
consistency rather than intensity um
always yeah
interesting uh there was something you
posted on instagram i think it was in
the last week or so where
it was like a screenshot of um your body
a few years ago versus now yeah and you
were highlighting some of the comments
you got around
um people are saying oh i looked better
before
what
and i i think you talked about in one of
the videos when in one of your stories
about how men don't really get that um
like that's
you know if a guy posts before and after
no one's commenting oh bro you look
better before
[Music]
what does that kind of feel like from
from your perspective and like what
i just wanted to try and try and
understand what it's like being
being a woman in the space
because you're dealing with that side of
things that men just don't deal with
yeah i mean look
there's a concept called billboard
bodies
and it's almost like if a girl has a
six-pack and then they're selling a
six-pack guide that six-pack guide would
do really well because there's a
billboard to prove
okay that the that's what the product
you'll get right
and men use that a lot in this industry
so a lot of the really like chiseled
guys incredible physiques
use their bodies as a way to promote
their product
that's what i do that's what i have done
you know everybody in the fitness
industry does that but i can't stress
that enough that that's just one aspect
of it not all aspects of it so when you
look at those before and afters that's
why in the caption i was saying that
before i was actually mentally exhausted
i was not okay i was not happy i felt
just not great
but the after is a byproduct of the
years i've put in to not only better
myself physically but mentally as well
no one reads captions
they're looking at two pictures side by
side and going you look better before
yeah you know
and that's fine
that doesn't affect me like no it
doesn't okay no way it used to not
anymore
but i think
for females
i can sit here and say oh it's more
difficult for women than it is for men
but the bottom line is i could always
also use the fact that i am a woman to a
huge
a huge advantage okay as in as in the
community i've built of women
can a man build a community like that
for women no
like i've used the fact that i'm a woman
to make other women feel really
confident in my space
to make them feel at home to make them
feel like they're part of a family
and i'm so thankful that i am a woman
because in my industry i was able to do
that um
interesting so you've got this like
although it is harder in that sense in
that you're dealing with these comments
which dudes might not deal with you also
have that kind of unfair advantage as it
were yeah of being able to build this
this like fantastic community people
telling me that they like my before i
i'm just happy to see a woman
lifting weights and like the the tags i
see every day like i see every single
instagram tag yeah i go for all of them
and i reply to them and i love seeing
them i see women in the gym i see them
with their best friends i see them with
other toner scott community members and
i'm just like this is it i love it nice
um
i wanted to end by talking about the
book a little bit so
um
how did
what was the story behind the book and
like how you got the book deal and what
was the story like what was the story
there
so look the book is one of those things
where it's a reminder
like when
when people open up do this for you i
want them to end this book with a
reminder to do this for themselves
and i give you loads of analogy as i
give you loads of like
you know it's very much so i i point
something out and then i give you an
example so if you're if you like reading
stuff like that it's great so i point a
situation out and then i give you an
example of that situation to help you
further kind of expand your
understanding
and if you have read it before i can't
encourage enough to go back and start
making notes okay
because each and every single chapter
will force you to think right and i see
so many people in this
using this book and i see post-it notes
everywhere
because they're just thinking out loud
and they're like oh yeah what about this
what if i do this what if i do that
it's a it's a thinking book it's not a
book where i'm telling you what to do
for for seven days how to eat how to
train
it's a book where i'm telling you to
think about your why in your fitness
journey and to remind you of your why
yeah nice
so
when
did the publisher like approach you for
it or did you decide yeah they
approached me how did that work i don't
thought i'd write a book i'm not gonna
lie i was
i'm actually a little bit dyslexic no a
lot dyslexic
so i find it very easy to to speak but
find it really hard to write
and um
actually the person that helped me write
this book was a community member oh
don't we so her name's zahara yeah and
oh she was in the acknowledgements at
the end yes
she was one of the original tony scott
crew
community members and i met her because
i invited her on set
and we just connected
she's complete she's one of a kind like
i've never met a person like her
and i knew my strengths were the
skeleton of the book i know
her background is teaching
and her background is
like writing
so i said to her help me write it you're
you know my voice you know my tone of
voice you know who you are who i am and
i know who you are so we did it together
yeah and i'm so happy we did because i
got her perspective on it as well like
how a community member would perceive it
and then me as a trainer how i would
write it yeah so i guess you're writing
the book for your community members so
that's like uh i was this isn't my
biography right
at the beginning
but this is a
help book this is me trying to help you
what was that process of getting all the
ideas onto the page and figuring out
okay these are the i don't know 12
chapters that we want like how did it
quite easy for me because i was a bit
like i kind of it was things i talk
about all the time like
it's things i always discuss all the
time so it was nothing out of the
extraordinary for me like you know
chapter one find your why you lose your
excuses maximize your time form healthy
habits is what we discussed shift your
perspectives what we've discussed
believe you can we've discussed it find
your tribe which is your community all
these things mean you've discussed so it
comes very natural it was just about
making them fit
perfectly in the book and how did you do
that pro like in the thing of making
them fit because it would be very easy
for it to turn into sort of a messy a
messy buzzfeed listicle kind of thing
which there's not any but i i was really
i was like oh one point
it like follows it flows really nicely
because every point is kind of the same
okay if you think about it like finding
your wire not making excuses they sit
hand in hand your first thing you need
to do is find your why like why are you
doing this the second thing to do is
right now let's drop all the excuses
behind your why right third thing is
okay let's find the time to execute your
why yeah so everything goes back to the
why
your tribe who is your tribe and why are
they your tribe
so everything always goes back back back
to that why
and
that's why i do wish my book was called
find your why but there's always a book
out there called find your wife yeah
so yeah
was it much of a struggle coming up with
the title
no no come on do this yeah it just it
just fits so nicely i mean so i'm i'm
i'm writing a book at the moment and
it's been such a struggle to figure out
what the hell the title is come to you
but you have to find your wife first
yeah that's the thing
i would sit you know what i would take a
day off work yeah
like just tell your team you know what
guys crack on with work i'm gonna just
don't contact me
and i would just go sit in a coffee shop
wherever you feel comfortable don't do
it at home um it gets too comfortable at
home
and i would just list all your whys
i'd list all your why's why you want to
do this why you want to be here why you
want to put this out in the world and
you'll start just right you'll start
free writing like it'll just be so
natural to you and then by the time you
realize it two hours have gone by yeah
then you're like taking compartments
brainstorming concepts yeah by the time
you realize four hours have gone by the
next day you've got your you've got your
title
um give it a go and send me a picture
okay
i want to see if you actually do it i'll
actually try that give it a go you never
know why the why exercise because i
spend so much time sitting in coffee
shops thinking what's the title going to
be but i've never it's already taken a
step back to things so yeah you need to
dissect it you need to really be like
why am i even writing a book
like what what is the reason behind this
book yeah why am i even here
because when you start asking yourself
you're like big questions yeah yeah but
they're really great questions because
they start getting your mind to think
some of the decisions we have
with tone and sculpt and honor active i
always go to team okay why
and they don't realize that i'm asking
them a really big ques big question
because of the way i'm saying this i'm
like okay why yeah and i had to drop it
in there and then they go because of
this this is imagine i go tell me the
why
they're like oh [ __ ] yeah that sounds
like a bigger deal so i'm like yeah okay
tell me why like why why are we doing
this
and then they don't realize that i do it
every single day to them okay
they don't realize like i go to my
design team by the way sometimes i know
the answer yeah and i'll go to my design
team
why are we doing that that line there i
know the answer yeah i just want to hear
how they perceive it okay
so
i've i i sort of sometimes do this with
my team and occasionally team members
will get frustrated that i'm i'm i'm not
trusting them enough and i'm questioning
their decision when i'm asking you know
what's what's the rationale here why why
are we doing it that way
do you get that sort of thing at all
from your team why are they getting
frustrated over you asking why
that encourages conversation that
encourages you to collaborate together
that encourages you to share each
other's thoughts
that shouldn't be offensive to them this
isn't you trusting having a trust issue
with your team this is you just
genuinely wanting to understand their
thought process yeah i always sit and
talk to my team actually sometimes where
we over collaborate like
sometimes a little bit
like guys stop now okay but it is so
beautiful when you see
people come together like my favorite
thing in the world
is when a can of worm is opened up in
the office
and a questions thrown out and i'm like
guys what do you think about this and i
do it on purpose i go guys what do you
think about this i'm unsure i know the
answer
and they're like hmm
they start talking and then they start
deliberating and then they start
constructively arguing
and i'm like amazing
this is it when you bring people
like-minded
with the same vision and mission in one
office
and they're just at it in a healthy way
they're at it in a very respectful
constructive way and you come out with
the best possible outcome if your team
doesn't challenge you
there's an issue you should challenge
them and they should challenge you i've
had so many team members before and my
team does not kiss my ass i can't
express that enough like my team will
say no to me
i'll say no we need to do this they go
no we need more time or they'll go no we
can do it sooner and i'm like no we need
more time and i'll go they'll go no
your team should be able to do that with
you they should be able to see you as
someone that they can collaborate with
not be afraid of yeah i guess when you
when you started building a team you
probably didn't have much experience of
managing and leading stuff how did you
learn that stuff over time
and i guess
what mistakes did you make though oh so
many yeah
so many mistakes like
no one tells you that people people are
going to be your biggest problem are
they no
yeah
no one told you that no one tells you
that staff is going to be your best
reward but your biggest issue as well
and
i've learned on the job and i've
literally faked it until i made it like
i've not i don't have a mentor
i don't um
[Music]
have like this
hidden
handy book
i've learned as i go along
but i can't stress enough to you that
the team you have are people
they're not machines they are people
and they require empathy
they require respect and they require to
have purpose okay like you have to treat
your team
like people
and so much many corporations forget
that people want weekends off
forget that people have children
and i'm so thankful that it's very rare
for me to ask an employee to to do more
than they should
but they want to yeah they want to do
more because they believe in what we
believe in and what i believe in they
genuinely like believe it so much that
they get emotional if it's not done
so like the other day we were picking
colors for 2022
and lisa head designer on active has a
child and i said go home like what are
you doing oh no no no it's fine i'll
i'll just stay yeah like she genuinely
wanted to stay not because i was there
but she was so intrigued by what we were
doing
and that's because i've shown her so
much respect and i've shown her so much
integrity and transparency and i've said
to her like i don't [ __ ] understand
this can you teach me it or i've said to
her like lisa what do i do i trust you
can you help me
you have to give people purpose
you have to say to your team i trust you
to do it yeah go do it let them make
mistakes okay
i guess i just learned along the way i
don't know where i got it from
were there some things that you did very
wrong in the early days yeah back on
yeah of course of course i made so many
mistakes
some of the mistakes i made was i got
too involved with my team like
saw the most friends lessons employees
one of the mistakes i made was you know
just
taking things too personally
one of the mistakes i made was also like
my reactions to things like i remember
especially during this whole
legal battle and my ending of my
relationship which is no excuse but to
put it in perspective
i would sometimes have major outbursts
and i would shout
and that's not good
that's not good at all
you know and i've come to the
to the realization that it's not about
me and it change it has changed over
time and it will continue to change
and i have some really great people
around me to come into my office and say
maybe deal with things differently next
time no nice
interesting that my my team does not
kiss my ass they might laugh on my joke
once in a while
do you search but no
do you do you do like goal setting and
like metrics and stuff for the team
i am right now turner's sculpt is way
more structured than on our active
simply because it's got
years more years than our way
honor active is in a very transitional
period right now like we're hiring um a
lot of exec department team leaders
which will come in and put kpis in place
we're in a period as well where we've
we've had a lot of growth so we're
trying to catch up with that growth with
the right team members so the first year
we made um 10 million revenue so to have
to make 10 million with a team
yeah to make 10 million revenue with a
team of five people yeah that's insane
that's not that's also not good that's
uh yeah it's a bit scary because it's
like we need more processes we need more
team members we need more suppliers like
so right now the team is more focused on
building more relationships with
suppliers that that have great um
ethical processes and we we want to work
with them
building more of their internal teams so
we hired a great head designer she was
actually head designer for sweaty betty
for 10 years which is incredible
um so she's come to honor active which
is huge success for us because she's
absolutely amazing at what she does yeah
so she's now building her team when she
builds her prices in her team she will
then build kpis and goals and whatnot
how how do you think about um
for like exactly the leadership
positions
promoting from within like the five
people you got started with and sort of
making them the exact team versus
bringing in people from from the outside
everyone you hire should be great
like everyone you hire
should be
so [ __ ] good
that they're able to come in one day to
your office and go
i'm leaving because i'm going to start
my own brand
and i go off you go okay that's how good
they should be
and i can safely say that
with both brands we have great people
and
you know great people that will get huge
promotions going forward because i don't
want to just bring someone else in
because they've been great in another
brand okay sure that might work for some
people
but for us it's like
no we have some great people here we can
nurture yes and if we have great people
that maybe require one ex one more year
extra to be
incredible let's just wait a bit okay so
you wouldn't hire someone in a position
kind of above them you would give them
that time to develop into that position
yes i would give them that time to
develop in that position but it depends
who they are so for example right now
for honor active we're in a process of
hiring a creative director so that
creative director is going to be
an exec
that's a huge big exact role right
so they will come in but they also they
already have kind of a team built
underneath them
but then you know i have an operations
manager at um on active who i see as my
right hand and one day i do see her as
an incredible exec role you know that
could lead a team without me there okay
so
it depends who it is it depends who you
have internally right now whereas we
have a graphic designer oa as well who i
see
beyond the graphic design i see her more
as an art director you know yeah but i
need more from her i need to test her a
bit more okay i need to give her a few
more
fires to take out and see how she
handles it but i know she's capable i
don't want to just bring it
bring people above other people i want
to give them time to prove themselves
you know okay
because then your team just feels like
there's no ladder there's nowhere to
progress there's nowhere to go with the
brand yeah and they just feel stuck and
you don't want people to feel like that
especially not your your your first hub
of people
interesting
so with with honorarta for example the
brand is going growing like ridiculously
fast presumably when you got to that
point of 10 million revenue with five
people i imagine you would have been
like oh crap we need we need to hire all
these people all at the same time no no
we already had the process so
um higher very very very very slow okay
higher slow
fire faster right yeah people say that
higher slow yeah take your time
understand people like when i hired my
head designer
i
it was covered time so i couldn't meet
her but i just had a call with her face
to face
and we spoke for about two hours and
then i and then when
restrictions were a bit okay i said come
to the office like
come and see what the team is like the
entire team was there and i was asking
her to fit me
okay throw them in deep and see how they
react
it's a culture thing as well do they fit
in your culture
because
my culture at oa
is nuts okay like the team is crazy and
crazy as in like
just a bunch of wild [ __ ] like
they're just
they're just a big family like they just
love the brand they love the community
they love the ethos but we are you could
we're like
we're family like it's a bunch of
cousins it's it's so bizarre it's like
we respect each other so much but we
also can go and have a crazy wild night
out and have the best memories
um and if someone comes in and can't
really fit that culture it's going to be
a bit hard on on the rest of the team
um
there's different personalities we have
introverts extroverts we have people who
like working alone people that like work
in a team but our our ethos is the same
our cultures are quite similar so how do
you how do you assess for culture fit
before someone is part of the team i
throw them in the team okay so when they
so
me and my operations manager were
actually discussing this and new
processes of hiring and from now on when
we interview someone we want to
interview them
in the office it's
pretty much like we have an open plan so
they're not they don't go to my office
they go to the sitting room wherever the
team can hear oh interesting what does
your hiring process look like at the
moment
so right now at the moment we're
headhunting a lot of people okay but
because we need to really accept roles
um but right now like we've taken
interns on as well
and we've thrown the interns and deep
end and we've been like
you wanna you wanna work with us
let's do this let's go okay everybody's
paid like we don't take interns or not
pay them like we don't believe in that
sort of stuff
everybody
needs to love the job and needs to love
the brand and they need to believe in
the brand okay if you do not believe in
the brand and you're just here for a
salary i will suss that out
i will suss that out
okay it's very easy to suss out when
you've got a great team um so with tone
and sculpt i imagine in the early
because with honor active it sounds like
you've already built a business once and
so maybe you had some of the processes
in place that you could like copy and
paste
whereas
okay everyone thinks this everyone
thinks that it's like oh you've got one
brand so it's just like bringing what's
going to be you know completely
different brands completely different
brands what honor active has tony scott
lacks what tone and scope has on our
active blacks
so what i mean by that is the processes
tonerscopt has and the infrastructure on
our active doesn't have currently so
we're building that we're starting with
baby like we're one years old like jesus
give us give us time you know
but uh
but you know five people in 10 million
revenue you know that's like ridiculous
levels of growth it is and it's scary
it's not the best thing when you grow
that fast trust me because you can go up
and you can go down so it's better to be
a bit more steady okay but um
on our active has a lot more
um
i would say
creativity okay
and more
um
focused on the mission
and then with toner scope because
there's more of us
it needs them there needs to be a
reminder because there's like triple the
people there so you have to more
actually
yeah there's going to be at the end of
the end of the year end of next year
we'll be about 60 people at tennessee
so
you have to ensure that the execs of
that company
filter through to the rest of the team
the core mission the core vision and it
can't be forgotten but because oa is so
small
you can't forget it because you're
speaking about it every day in an open
plan office you know how do you split
your time between the two
so i actually have a three story office
uh on active sits at top and two floors
down two floors are tone and sculpt okay
so i'm up and down speaking of time
management we're going to take a very
quick break to introduce ryze who are
sponsoring this week's episode rise is a
desktop app for mac os and windows that
helps you understand where your time is
going while you're browsing the internet
by automatically tracking the time you
spend on apps and websites they've got
some pretty sick features too like smart
break notifications that let you know
when to take breaks based on your
activity and they also give you in-depth
analysis of how you're dividing your
time between deep work meetings and all
that jazz so you can find out where you
can reclaim your focus optimize your
time and be more productive if you fancy
trying it out i've got a cheeky promo
code where the first 1000 signups will
get a 25 discount off of their first
three months just type in ali abdul and
caps rise also offer a 14 day free trial
so you can test it out beforehand so
there's no reason not to give it a go so
thank you very much rise for sponsoring
this episode now let's jump back into
the conversation
so what does like uh your day look so
you wake up wake up a half five do the
gym training breakfast commute stuff
until 10.
so the office at 10 first meeting is at
10. okay so
yesterday for example i had meetings 10
till 6.
okay no break well
right do you like that
um i like i like to eat for 10 minutes
yeah
but uh yeah it's like
one after the other and it's like i
cannot be late
you have that time with me tell me what
we need to do tell me what we need to
work on if you go over my time sorry
i've got to go
okay
i have to be very like
cut throat okay unfortunately even
though the conversation's great i've got
places to be and people to see yeah so
is that what most of your days are like
sort of back-to-back meetings for
lunchtime back to back-to-back meetings
or if i have anything like out of my
ordinary schedule like this for example
but it is back to back and then i have a
nine til 10 p.m slot where i review
documents
in the evening
so i'll get home
so i'll get the office at 10 then i'll
leave the office around about
seven okay now
and then i get home about
8 15.
and then i'll eat
say hello to my partner 9 p.m i'll crack
on with more work
um till about eleven
yeah rest back at it wow that's quite
the schedule so you get like six and a
half hours of sleep each night six hours
yeah six hours do you find that works
for you yeah nice
on weekends i sleep more okay but it
works it works it works really well it
depends like i'm a woman as well like
time of the month i need more rest you
know
um
but yeah it works well i do have a cr i
do crash
3 pm okay
and like i'm like oh my god where's my
caffeine and like i i i do actually find
myself laying on the sofa and the team
has to have meetings with me laying on
the sofa sometimes
because i we actually bought a little
sofa bed um downstairs at chinese called
it's like a big bed so sometimes like
with the tone sculpting my tom just sit
there with me and
sometimes i do shut my eyes and i'm
still listening okay
but i listen i take everything in
um but
i have a rule like emails can't be too
long i can't i can't sit there and read
emails all day
meetings can't be longer than
i try to keep meetings 30 minutes at
time
if they're really important one hour
um
i also tell terry my personal assistant
like i have to have fridays as a
creative day where i think yeah and i go
to the brands and i look at the road
maps and i shift things around i change
things i work on weekends as well yeah
i tend to have saturdays off by work
sundays okay and i guess you live your
life by your calendar yeah see where you
do i wake up and be like okay cool
that's what i've got yes where's the
case of oh [ __ ] that's what i got no no
i wake up and i go right this is what we
need to achieve great
let's go
well
yeah
um
you don't run two companies by having
free time yeah
but like today for example you know it's
been a little bit more relaxed it's been
a bit more my mum and dad were home so
it was a little bit more chilled and i i
had my meetings at home in the morning i
had three meetings and then i had you
know to revise a few contracts on the
train
and then i came to the office we did a
another meeting and then a
product review with the team yeah now
here
okay but i do have a now appointment
today so that's great if it's free time
that'll be good are you going to review
contracts while doing that or i said to
have meetings when i have no
appointments so there's every time i go
to the hair salon um
my hairdresser i've played for about
seven years yeah he he's like i've got
your chargers ready for you oh amazing
he knows that he knows the deal like i'm
sorry i'm trying to i'm trying to run
like two incredible brands yeah time is
like money honey like i gotta go go go
that's the hustle
um changing gears a bit uh i was
listening to your interview with stephen
bartlett uh which was just under a year
ago oh yeah yeah and in that
i think you were single at the time and
you both talked about how you're
difficult to date
and then i saw a youtube video from a
few months ago where you kind of
revealed your your new partner in things
yeah and i wanted to ask like
it's it sounded like when you were
talking to stephen you were kind of
struggling with the dating thing feeling
like work was the priority and and stuff
but now at least from from what i've
seen on youtube it seems like you're
thriving in this new relationship um
works always the priority okay
work is like i you know
i am so happy in my relationship like i
i am so happy i've met brett and he's
just
he is everything i i
he is everything that i could want
and
he's patient he's calm
he calms me he makes me laugh he's
understanding he has never once said to
me
babe can you get off your phone okay
he's never said that
he understands that
i have a job to do and i have a purpose
to fulfill
and at the beginning it was a bit hard
to explain that to him
he doesn't have social media
he's he has a phd in chemistry like he
works in a lab all day um he's a very
like he's home home family man like
that's what he's like he loves his
family and he he loves like being with
his brothers and his mom and his dad and
you know being at home with me and my
dog so
he didn't understand the complexity and
the velocity of how important these jobs
are and what my role was
so what i decided to do was bring him on
set
okay so i bought him on set and i i
you know
brought him around the team and then he
would spend like a day with me and kind
of see how my day was and he was like
whoa
and he realized how intense it was
because at first instance he thought i
posted selfies all day
he was like oh so what'd you do like
first selfies and i was like yeah
i mean it seems like he's in a very
different industry to you i mean apart
from that his his arm's absolutely huge
yeah is that how he's got good
how did you guys meet uh in the gym oh
okay i saw him and i was like oh he's a
bit amazing he's always a bit handsome
and then
one thing led to another we got speaking
he wasn't interested in me okay at all
he was so focused on his phd completing
it that he was not interested in anyone
and i was like okay no problem we won't
talk i'm not chasing
and then we didn't speak for three
months and then we kind of
our paths collided again and then
we got speaking
he fell in love with me no joking we
both like fell for each other heart
really really really hardly yeah and
yeah we've been together now about a
year
and a bit
um but when i was speaking to stephen it
was a three-month gap
oh oh that's one okay got it yeah so it
all makes sense now oh interesting so um
yeah yeah yeah
brett is just
he just puts a smile on my face he makes
me happy he puts a smile on my face he's
he's very very very just sometimes like
where's the common sense but then you
can't have both you know book smart and
common sense like come on you've got to
give them you'll give a guy something
okay so yeah he he's great
um how did you so if he doesn't have
social media and stuff how did how did
you navigate the whole sort of to what
extent you wanted the relationship to be
public versus private i asked him i said
do you feel comfortable with it if you
don't we i never need to showcase you
i can tell people i'm taken but we don't
need to publicly announce that he was
like no like
if you want to
we can
i i he goes to me but if i say like
maybe no to videos just respect that and
i said of course like i'm not going to
shovel yeah
sometimes he's a bit difficult and i'm
going to just be in it and then he's
like don't want to be in it today and
i'm like okay no problem but then
there's other moments where he's like
let's take a picture and he like gets
into it okay so
he's he's really chilled he is he's the
guy that really puts he puts me first
he doesn't put himself as he puts me
first he knows that if i need to be on
my laptop working he doesn't disturb
he knows that when i am giving him
attention in the sense of when i'm not
on my phone
like that's
genuine quality time
because i don't give a lot of people
that and i have to be honest like i
don't give people that quality time
because i don't even have it for myself
i don't like i am giving it to my brands
so he respects that and a lot of guys
wouldn't respect that okay a lot of guys
would be like get off your phone or you
never spend time with me or you're not
texting me back like i think we text in
the morning and a few times during the
day and that's it
i'm on my phone to work
i don't socialize on my phone i don't
have time to socialize very rare
and i don't want it to change like i
love my life i don't want to go out
clubbing and drinking every single
weekend that's not for me you know okay
so
i've been i've been dating someone for a
few months and yeah okay she
is very concerned about the whole public
spotlight oh she's a bit nervous yeah
um have you have you had any like
negative repercussions from being
semi-public about the relationship or
relationships in the past
no i think i think because a lot of
people saw my relationship with jack
they were a bit they were really upset
when me and jack did part ways because
they felt like so connected to me and
jack yeah but then now they've seen me
and brett they they're like i'm so happy
for you
i think don't do anything that puts
pressure on her but i think three months
is very soon so just like give her some
more time yeah and i think why not bring
her to one of your work days
why not let her like kind of sneak peek
into your like your genuine work
um because it will make her feel more
comfort comfortable and confident and
just be open with her and say hey like
no pressure but the reason i want to
publicly announce she is because you
know i think you're the one so why not
celebrate that
okay interesting um did you feel like
given that yours and jack's relationship
was was public was there
more pressure to keep it going even when
things weren't working yeah
okay yeah 100 we
i had checked out in my head a long time
ago and i think jack had to yeah jack's
in a really happy relationship now he's
so in love with his new partner and you
know we haven't met yet but i really
like when we do meet
i just want to say to her listen honey
you've got nothing to worry about
i know it's a bit awkward i get it but
i just want him to be happy okay and i
know we weren't happy with each other
anymore for a while and we were really
just like trying to make it work
so he's happiness to me is absolutely
everything
and i guess that's that's one of the
risks of having a public relationship
it's sort of like it's hard to break up
with someone once you moved in with them
because there's like an extra layer of
pressure
and a company and you're in a car yeah
you own a dog
it was a lot but but um yeah no we we
were very very very respectful there was
no bitterness there was no aggression
there was no
nastiness there was
you're still part of this brand this is
still your home if you want your share
sure if you want to sell it we'll sell
it together like it was very
amicable unbelievable i cannot i could
never say that word administerable
amicable
i'm a convolutional yeah
and sometimes i just mess up words but
yeah yeah yeah no he we're very
respectful to one another we have
blowouts here and there for work
but you're going to you have pressure
you have a team of 30 people and
employees to pay and salaries to pay and
you know these people are putting food
on on their on their kids on the table
for their kids it's a big responsibility
our people's mortgages is mental
do you ever worry about like security
because you're like on the train and
stuff and i imagine being free all of
that okay i mean for the office i did
because we have a lot of stuff in the
office
and i
want to take care of my employees
but
like personal security and stuff no i've
just been saying i've just been hearing
a lot of like horror stories
usually from from youtubers in america
actually where they're like if they if
anyone gets a whiff of what their
location is or where their office could
be or even something in the background
of one of their stories people figure
out where they live and come to the
house and it's all like
i'd have been like oh [ __ ] no i'm not at
it i have no i have i'm alarm systems
and security in my house yeah okay
um but
i'm comfortable getting on trains and
yeah i don't i don't think anyone wants
to hurt me okay well
i hope i don't need to put the thought
in your head but damn now you've really
got me thinking but no i'm i'm okay okay
amazing um i've just got a few kind of
rapid fire questions sure if you're if
you're down for that number one i'll say
yes or no is that is that this kind of
thing uh potentially maybe one-liners
fine no problem okay let's go what
advice would you give to your younger
self
be patient excellent who's had the
biggest influence on your career the
community nice uh what's one tip for
someone looking for success don't make
it profit driven make it vision driven
nice um
what does the first and last hour of
your day look like
you really wanna know
first hour waking up and heading to the
gym last hour checking my
tag pictures for my community
um what material item under 100 pounds
could you not live without oh god my
honor active
excellent
what book other than yours would you
recommend to anyone built to last oh
interesting i haven't read that i'm
gonna read that tonight if you lost
everything how would you start a
business again with my vision and
mission and my why amazing what quote or
mantra do you live by do this for you
excellent and finally journey or
destination journey
always the journey i was thinking
holidays then and i was like i'd be fun
but no uh jenny always amazing
chrissy thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me
thank you so much for opening and honest
and then about everything always a bit
too open and honest
but i hope everyone enjoyed it but thank
you so much for having me yeah thanks
for coming on and uh yeah links to all
your things will be in all the things
everyone check the book out
it's very good the tagline had to be a
strong woman from inside out i sort of
chuckled a bit when i posted that on my
instagram story but it's like genuinely
i mean there's there's a little bit
about pregnancy and trimesters and stuff
yeah but beyond that
it's all very it's all very gender
neutral so
yeah thank you thank you so much